all right it looks like we're live now
for
our second philosophy pop-up uh second
in this month and um
second overall as well
and i pulled my patreon supporters about
what they wanted me to talk about
martin heidegger won over stoicism
aristotle was a distant third
so this month we're talking about some
topics in heidegger
i actually have some some stuff that i i
was thinking about that i i planned
um but then i'll just open it up to any
sort of questions or comments um they
can be about heidegger they can be about
philosophy in general they can be about
about other stuff
so um
yeah i think that that's probably enough
said about that
so
heidegger is one of those thinkers um
who you know like like many of the other
people that i i work on
and incorporate and
shoot videos on and sometimes even do
classes on
i you know i think there's some really
valuable stuff in his work and then i
disagree with him on
on some other things
um so i'm not a high tagarian anymore
that i'm a hegelian uh even though i do
the half hour hegel series but i but i
do think that heidegger is somebody
who's really important to
spend some time studying
um
i can't say that i ever went through a
heideggerian phase
and i think that
part of the reason for that was because
when i when i was in graduate school
i mean first of all i i really only
encountered heidegger in graduate school
we had to read them a little bit as an
undergrad
uh because existentialism was really big
where i went to uh undergraduate which
no longer has a philosophy program by
the way
um
and um so i read some heidegger i i
can't say i understood anything other
than this idea of being towards death
which you know and that anxiety was very
important um but then when i got to grad
school there were actually um quite a
few other grad students who really
thought that heidegger was the guy or
the philosopher to study
um i would say that you know so the
southern illinois university carbondale
graduate department
in philosophy was what we call
pluralistic department there were
representatives of continental
philosophy analytic philosophy and
classical american and even some history
philosophy people
so
heidegger was really one of the big
thinkers i would say in the continental
side
just as big as say dewey was in the
american side
and i'm trying to think of i mean they
were into lewis
and uh chisholm and people like that on
the analytics side dennett as well
um
and then you know i started reading
heidegger and and so anyway there were
these people that were sort of convinced
heideggerians and
i didn't really like them
you know i i you know when you get into
these long discussions that go over you
know semesters with the same people you
get to know a lot about
you know not just the philosopher that
you're supposed to be talking about and
reading but but maybe also about what
what other people think are really the
most important themes
and you know i was very into philosophy
of language so people like well you've
got to read heidegger because you know
language is the house of being
and i you know on my own i did i did
find a lot of profound insights into
language
in heidegger and its connections with
other things but i wasn't getting it
from the high tagarians so so i never
really became a hydarian of any sort
now you know what i wanted to talk about
i was thinking about this this morning i
i get a lot of youtube questions
and sometimes occasionally you know
people emailing me
or messaging me in other social media
like facebook or twitter and
um
a lot of these questions turn on
you know the issue of well
what what should i be reading in
philosophy and
often there's
it's not just asking for sort of a menu
list you know we'll read these these
guys
um
and do it in this order or something
like that there is a
a worry
behind it that somehow
somebody is going to miss out on
what's most essential in philosophy
and
this is a really interesting issue i
think i'll probably do a video about
this when i can find the time later on
um
you can get yourself you know a history
of philosophy
like you know cobblestones i mean if you
want a
good reliable one you you pick something
like that or a more recent one or you
can get some you know fairly
idiosyncratic history of philosophy
which sort of
selects in different ways
and you're getting a a listing of who is
important to engage in and and you're
probably going to miss some people in
there who might have been interesting to
read
that you might only come across
if you're you know digging through the
stacks in the library or following up on
some footnotes and somebody else like
for example
somebody who i really like um is this
guy and i'll actually write his name
down
on the side
um
he's not not read by a lot of people but
his name is lev shestoff he was a
a uh ethnically jewish
um
russian philosopher who wound up being
transplanted to to france uh you know he
had to flee after the russian revolution
and um his works were very interesting
but how would how would you come across
him you know um
there's there's a couple different ways
but most people don't don't know much
about him he has mentioned by the way in
kamu's
myth of sisyphus
i always get that mixed up synthesis
anyway
um
he's mentioned as one of the
existentialists so you might follow up
on that now how how would you find out
who you should actually study
um well the best that you can go by is
some sort of recommendations by somebody
else or doing your own digging around
and you know maybe following things out
yourself we're always operating in the
conditions so here's where we get back
to heidegger of what heidegger talked
about as finitude
um we are not and we can never really
place ourselves we can imagine ourselves
we can never really place ourselves
in a kind of
god's eye position you know
we're always operating
on the basis of
insufficient information
sometimes more sometimes less
and this applies to you know
when we engage in what's essentially
practical decision making about where we
ought to put our time
and thought and attention like when
we're deciding what to study in
philosophy
so i think it's perfectly legitimate
for people to get recommendations and
then to you know read those things and
then maybe get some more recommendations
and you know do some reflection and
revision of what their plans are
and just to keep you know plowing away
at it so if i tell you you know well i
think you should start with plato
um but somebody else tells you no no you
have to read all the pre-socratics you
know what we have of them first
i mean you could pick either either path
and that's okay and then somebody else
might tell you um well you know just get
yourself a good secondary history of
philosophy before tackling the first
stuff or get yourself a a nice
introductory text
and i would say no no read the the
primary text
and you can get into philosophy any of
those ways but i think a lot of people
get very anxious
about um
getting into philosophy and whether
they're going to do the right thing or
do the wrong thing and here's the thing
um
you you can't possibly in your lifetime
read all the philosophical works that
are out there
you can't even
read all of the
you know great thinkers
uh in a
really attentive adequate way
in your lifetime particularly if you
have to work for a living like all
all of the people that i know do you
know i don't know anybody who's
independently wealthy at this point
um
and so you know
you're you're operating in conditions of
finitude and think about this too you
know you don't want to spend all of your
your available time just reading and
reflecting on philosophy i mean that's
kind of nice but
you also do want to live a life so that
that philosophy connects up with other
things too and you want to meet other
people and talk with them about this so
we're you know we're always sort of
doing our best in these these conditions
of finitude
and you can say similar things about
studying other things or about how you
learn from experience and gradually
improve the relationships that you have
with the people in your life who some of
whom are dying some of whom are
disappearing some of whom are moving on
and changing in in various ways
you can say this about you know the
talents that you develop i don't know
for
art or music or you know your your your
body and it's athleticism what what
there is of that
we we work with what we have
and i think
this is i'll just say this and then i'll
start answering some questions or taking
comments um
so
uh and you just use the chat thing um
by all means to to ask whatever you'd
like um there's so i gave you kind of
you know something that's kind of bad
news right well you can never really
take it all in
you can conceive of somebody doing that
but that's purely imaginary it's not
really possible for for us
um and the more that you do philosophy
the more you discover this to be the
case
um but there is good news too and there
the good news comes in in two ways i
think
one is that it can be liberating to find
out that you don't have to do it all
that you can't do it all so you don't
have to do it all
um i think there's a lot of people who
who think that unless they
are taking in the totality of
philosophical thought they're somehow i
don't know letting philosophy down or
letting themselves down
or something along those lines and that
doesn't have to be the case
um as a matter of fact it's it's a
it's an unrealistic
demand to place upon yourself
the other thing is
even though we can't read everybody
and
compare all of them to each other and
reflect on them and and critically
analyze all of them
uh and we can only really do just a
portion and we forget half of what we've
read anyway if you're like me
[Laughter]
we can still get to the heart of things
it's still possible for us to
to
get at what's what's essential that's
what's amazing about this i mean imagine
think back to like you know ancient
times and imagine that you are a monk
in a monastery and um that's one you
know this is in the west of course
this is one of the places where learning
has been preserved from all those you
know disorders and tumults and and
and waves of of people invading and and
culture essentially getting lost
and you've got a library and in your
library
you might have plato's timaeus
maybe
and you probably have aristotle's
categories
and boethius's commentary on it and
maybe a few other things and you might
have some some seneca
and you might have some some cicero um
[Music]
and you definitely have a few you know
very important and interesting christian
authors like augustine and john cassian
um and you know and you've got
a few other things to read here and
there maybe somebody even wrote
something at your monastery that's worth
reading
now could you get to
the heart of the matter of human
existence
on that basis
and applying your own thought
and think about the big the big
questions
yes you can i mean
you you might not um have the same sort
of thoughts that you would have if you
were able to encounter people who are
coming
centuries after you in time which would
include by the way other other people in
that situation like say saint anselm
right or are these scholastics like
thomas aquinas or or kant or heidegger
or hegel or any of those people but you
can still think what is really
essential
and we're in a similar situation today
in our case the issue is not
that we don't have enough books the
issue is that we have an embarrassment
of riches that we can't possibly
digest and get through and even curate
all that well um because there's just so
much out there
but there's i mean the good news is so
much of it is great stuff that if we
grapple with we can we can get something
out of it
so uh i'm not seeing any any questions
in the chat window here so i am going to
check uh stuff on
um
social
media and see because i know somebody
asked a question in facebook
and see if i can't maybe also
get the um
questions
coming through in uh the other
format
um
with it i mean in youtube in part
because this is my first time
playing around with with youtube live in
a very long time
um
all right so uh bella konfar asked on
facebook and i'll actually i'll just put
this in the
chat window so everybody else can
see it
do i think there's a philosopher that
speaks to us and can teach us more than
other philosophers in this present
moment
um
so that's a great question
is there a philosopher
uh no i don't think so
are there
philosophers plural
uh definitely yes
um
and i mean
what i what i'm gonna say really
reflects the kind of uh people that i'm
reading and engaging with
um
so
let's start by talking about people who
are actually
still on the scene
and um
you know doing doing work now
i would say one of the people who i
particularly like in that respect is
aleister mcintyre um i'm a big fan of
his
uh he's still producing new work which i
think is is uh quite quite admirable
he's in his 80s very very sharp mind
a guy who
i've been fortunate enough to get to
know a little bit and who i know
is the real deal when it comes to virtue
ethics and who is very practically
oriented um
[Music]
so yeah um somebody who i don't know who
i i think is is quite interesting
and who
um whose works i i get a lot out of
although i often disagree with him is
jurgen habermas
i also like
and i haven't read enough of him to
really have a great
um
uh you could say great um
overview picture is is giorgio ogenben
um but i think that the stuff that i've
read is very interesting and very timely
um
i really enjoy
you know reading
julia annis
um or it might be honest should know
since i've met her at stoic on uh that
was sort of like getting to meet a rock
star
um i think that a lot of the stuff that
she does in terms of ancient philosophy
is incredibly relevant to our own time
um
you know and and so i mean we could pick
other people it when we talk about who
else is particularly
relevant
um i think that um you know
so a lot of people take heidegger as
somebody who
really one ought to start with you know
my wife is
a phd candidate with european graduate
school which is this really cool
sort of high intensity low residency
graduate program originally started by
darida and some other people
in base in switzerland and malta and
they've got some outreach in new york
and um they really you know they're
they're
mostly focused on continental stuff of
course
and they they
treat heidegger almost sort of like uh
preliminary reading sort of like a lot
of programs might say all right we need
to start with some plato and some
aristotle i think they they take
heidegger that way um
who else in the the you know 20th
century what i say is really really
important in that way and has a lot to
teach us
um i you know i'm
i i hesitate to recommend him because he
decided to write in such an obscure
manner
in his
uh which i think is is a
bad decision on his part i understand
why he did it but i'll say it is you
know i'll invoke him anyway jacques laca
i think is really worth
engaging with but i suggest instead of
reading the acry first you know engaging
with some of the seminars which are much
more readable
um
you know when it comes to
to some of the issues
going on in our own time in terms of you
know gender relations and stuff like
that
um
it's it's interesting to go to somebody
like
you know say to bouvoir who who by the
way does a great job in completing
the ethics that sark was never able to
get around doing in in her ethics of
ambiguity but i'm i'm a big fan i think
as a lot of people know of somebody
who's much much earlier but who's
thought i think is very relevant in our
time
and that is
mary wollstonecraft
somebody else who i think is is
particularly
worth um spending time with and and
thinking in terms of uh where we are in
our historical situation is hana rent
um
and of course you know in order to if
you read some of these people i think
that you know one of the things that
that'll come out of it
is um
[Music]
they're going to make you want to read
other people
you know so
if you read a rent
and you don't want to go back and read
more plato and aristotle and augustine
um
or read some nietzsche or you know some
other thinkers you're probably not
reading a rent right
same thing with reading mcintyre or you
know julianis or
any any of these these these people um
they're
that's that's actually sort of a virtue
in in philosophy i suppose for
philosophical authors that they get you
to
not just read them
but want to go back and reread
other people
that they're part of a vast conversation
and i think that's kind of a different
model
of philosophy than we we often see
in um analytic or even in much
continental philosophy
um
this notion of philosophy as being a
genuine ongoing critical conversation
um
as opposed to you know
just
much more
circumscribed
discourses
so i see we have about 85 people
watching
i'm happy to take any any questions i'm
not seeing any in the chat so let me go
over to
the youtube
interface and see if i
see anything
posted in there
remember i think you can you can use
your your
chat
um
all right so
um
ah
here we go
here's the live chat i'm not i'm not
sure why i'm not actually
seeing it here but there is a ton of
stuff all right so i need to look in
in this portion um
all right reading back up a lot of
hellos and greetings from people
um
i am going to start just taking things
as i see them here so i apologize for
not answering these questions earlier
now i now i see how to how to do it in
this this thing
um
uh so paul deigert asks an important
question did heidegger ever denounce the
nazi party no he did he did not and um
i suppose it's worth saying a little bit
about the nazi thing
um especially since you know you know
since the black notebooks came out
that's that's really a
major
clincher
and
[Applause]
so my my view is that we can we can
dissociate you know a lot of ideas from
um
heidegger's
philosophy from his his nazism there's
some ideas that i think that you know
probably
uh feed into it you know i mean the fact
that he was able to
view um hitler as you know sort of this
whatever we want to call it something of
being
on the scene um that's very troubling
right um but that's not something that's
i think intrinsic to all of his
philosophy so
all right um xenia guerilla says did you
read the english translation i bet he's
a very interesting oh she's responding i
think to chino ashrae's very interesting
philosopher to translate
heidegger is difficult to translate when
i was taking
my heidegger seminar in graduate school
i i was reading him in class in the
german
and uh you know then i would compare
sometimes with the available
translations mockery's translation and
then this
more recent stambaugh
translation
um
nowadays
i have to admit i'm a bit lazy i tend to
read it in translation
unless i want to you know really look
closely at a passage or if i'm shooting
a video on it then i look at the german
um
meta nomad has uh what they call a
really specific question do you see any
overlap between heideggerian thought and
and levinos's philia
um
well i mean
levine us is definitely engaging
heidegger i'll say a broader thing first
that um
there's kind of a genealogy in
continental philosophy in terms of
phenomenology
um
that shows the real difference between
like
continental philosophy and
real european philosophy and when i say
real european philosophy i mean
something that's different than the
truncated version of what was going on
in the continent that we have here that
gets taught as continental philosophy
so you know phenomenology gets said that
to begin with with huss role but it
really didn't um it's beginning with
with both huss rule and shaler
um it's coming out of you know
brentano's thought
bergstone and blondel before hiding
before his role is doing what he's doing
or doing things very very similar to
phenomenology so there's a lot of people
sort of working in that field at the
time
and the the standard genealogy goes
hustle heidegger you know
uh marilyn ponties start loving us all
kind of on the same thing derrida marion
henry you know and just skip everybody
else um
and and so i i want to say there's a lot
more going on in phenomenology and all
these people are reading each other and
responding to each other
so yeah there's there's a lot of
connections between them all right
skipping down a bit
um
so here's here's an interesting thing
from nick weech i think it's pronounced
might be wait
his question concerning technology and
the modern reliance on smartphones and
social media never mind mcluhan it's
gone much further hasn't it yeah i think
that that's a great point
um
the notion of treating things as
standard reserve
um
that you find discussed in
the the question concerning technology
this sort of you know reduction of the
scope of being to what can be let's
let's actually just call it what can be
given metrics right to use the
contemporary term
um i think that the question concerning
technology is is a great piece about
that
now it's interesting to bring up mcluhan
because mcluhan is interested in the
generally mcluhan is doing compare
contrast right hot and cold media um
that's why i think some of his analyses
are very interesting but often are a
little bit too
schematic and binary
and
you know where where does things like
cell phones or social media fit in well
they're kind of image based they're kind
of writing um
you know it's not entirely clear how we
should understand them
but heidegger is is is getting at
how does technology and our
sort of obsession with
our iphones and things
um really cut into
our capacity for appreciating other
kinds of being you know think about for
example
the the food porn uh phenomena right all
these people taking pictures of their
food and being more interested in how
many likes it gets because of the
plating and and all of that and plating
is important in a culinary sense right
um but really taste is
is probably at the essence
of food
you know i don't know we could say a lot
more about that so there's
there's uh some really good
um
berry do d treasurer asked dr sather
what do you think of jordan peterson
eileen conservative but regardless of
his politics i personally think his
understanding of philosophy especially
post-modernism is embarrassing well this
will probably be a little embarrassing
for me but i have not read his maps of
meaning i've looked at his website in
the past and i've you know a lot of
people have recommended him to me so
i've listened to you know a bit of his
stuff but i i frankly don't get as much
time as i'd like to to to
stay up on other people in the field you
know it's sort of a treat for me to get
to
um spend time
watching or listening to some of the
other people who i
i you know work with like um well
somebody who recently interviewed jordan
peterson um and i'll mention him by name
here a cliff sergeant who does the
better than food book reviews uh which i
particularly
like
um but even that i don't get to
to check that out uh very often now
jordan peterson
um
so i i can't really comment on his
understanding of post-modern i'll say
this that a lot of people are using this
term postmodern
in a way that um
to me seems kind of strange
you know because there isn't a single
postmodern
uh and i don't think there ever really
was even when post-modernism was was a
young identifiable movement you know
people like leotard and jameson were
able to identify a number of different
ways in which you can understand it
and you know what's being signified by
it um
i i i you know i actually when it comes
to this is something i thought the thing
about doing a dr sadler's soap box about
you know the gender pronoun thing
um i get where peterson is coming from
because you know
there's there's kind of a well
what next kind of
response to the we should add all sorts
of things in
i personally kind of like the
although there are some downsides to it
i kind of like that let's just go to
they let's use day for everybody you
know because yeah that would simplify my
writing so much
i use he or she typically
um
i don't do the you know typical
philosopher thing of putting it all in
the female gender switching back and
forth between them
i also don't do the you know mankind
versus humanity
or stuff like that i wish we could you
know
i kind of wish we could we could like
dispense with with that because to me
that's kind of a low-level issue
compared to the bigger issues that we
have to grapple with
so
all right let's see what else we've got
oh here's an interesting one
pablo camparino my question is this
could you talk about the relationship
between wittgenstein and heidegger what
do they have in common do you see them
as expressions of the same movement in
different sides of the discipline
so
i'll say this there are quite a few
people who are attracted to that notion
that wittgenstein and heidegger
are you know doing similar things great
example that would be richard rorty
who lines them also up with john dewey
i don't find that very convincing
i will also say this too
i mentioned aleister mcintyre
in an interview that mcintyre did with
kinesis which is the graduate school
journal
from
the southern illinois university
carbondale department of philosophy
mcintyre actually
said that he considered
both both wittgenstein
and heidegger
to be important philosophers but
important in different ways he thought
that heidegger
um important in part because he was
wrong about
so many things and his his erroneous
perspective has had such a deleterious
influence
on philosophy he thought that
wittgenstein was right important because
he was right about
some things um
so
now you know
wittkenshein and heidegger are both
interested in language they're both
interested in what we could call the
pragmatics of language not just you know
analyzing semantics i actually put in a
jibe
about you know the recent existentialist
comic
post about
you know
the
metaphysicians who become sort of a you
know
sort of like captain planet
versus wittgenstein
um and i ribbed him a little bit because
you know he said that that you know
wittgenstein was all about semantics
wittgenstein is also about how we use
language to do things
that was what was really revolutionary
in vickinstein's
attitude the whole notion of language
game and language involved with form of
life you know all of that is coming out
of there but i think that
um
i mean there are some some other
similarities in what they're combating
right they're they're both against a
kind of cartesianism
uh
but i don't really see that many
connections between them frankly i think
we can make connections
in interesting ways between them sort of
like
we can be eclectic in philosophy and say
i can connect up some things here in
stoicism with some things in
aristotelianism and make a better
synthesis
but i don't i don't see them as i don't
see them as intrinsically connected
um
tommy l asks what's your view on
technocracy in light of what's happening
at the white house these days
shouldn't the attorney general of the
state or country be a professor of law
for example and so on
um
yeah i think that's sort of a that
should be a minimal
well
professor of law no i don't think they
should be a professor of law i think
that they should be
a
practicing jurist
um
but i'm not you know as somebody who
came from inside of the academy
uh it's sort of like knowing how the
sausage is made
there's so much
there's so much that's very contingent
and
really
in certain ways
what's the word not nepotistic
not corrupt but something along those
lines in academics
that i don't have much trust you know
when i when i see that that somebody has
a you know that they're teaching at
harvard or their degree is from yale or
blah blah blah blah i'm not particularly
impressed um
when i i want to actually see their work
you know and i want to interact with the
person if possible to gauge myself
whether they're just a you know a dud
or um
who managed to make the right contacts
and go to the right school and
have the right grooming uh and is lucky
enough to win what we call the academic
lottery or whether they're the real deal
that said i've met some people from
elite schools who have really impressed
me um
but i've met pontius so so i don't think
that's that important
to know what the hell you're doing
uh
and so you know i'd rather have you know
real practicing lawyers
as attorney general
how does this connect with technocracy
um i'm not sure i see the connection
there between the two
um
let me take some other ones why is
marcus so hard to read this comes from
arya
gazavi
um
well
so
interestingly
when it comes to critical theorists i
think that marcusa
is actually easier to read than some of
the other ones like say tandoori dorno
right or even even jurgen habermas
but marcuzzi is hard to read and marcus
is hard to read i think in large part
because there's a lot of jargon there
and this is this is similar to a lot of
philosophers
um and the question that i think we
often have to ask ourselves is well is
is the jargon
really necessary to convey the thought
or or is it
just kind of showing off i think in the
case of a lot of
secondary literature and sort of you
know
i'm inspired by this person a lot of
times the jargon is a substitute for for
thinking it's it's it's uh
it's working with a kind of linguistic
machine that turns out interesting
results
um not confined to philosophy but
historians do this
lit crit people do this
you know
futurists do this pick all sorts of
people um that's a common thing
sometimes the jargon really is needed
and then you got to figure out what the
code of that jargon is and when you do
it unlocks things you know i had an
interesting comment on a video recently
that was on one of the category videos
and the person was saying
in these these videos
you know i don't know why the hell
aristotle had to write in such a complex
way
and i said well i'm glad the videos
helped you
but the reason why aristotle wrote in
such a complex way for this work is
because he's grappling with
complex realities and so the language
needs to be adequate to
um what he's trying to grapple with and
so the person said
you know i try to take these passages
and translate them into simpler ways of
expressing it
i said well that's that's a good that's
a good thing to do
um
but you got to watch out that you're not
oversimplifying you know sometimes to go
back to this point sometimes the
terminology really does need to be there
all right let me
go back down i think
here we go
philip uh domini wrote perhaps you
should give us a top 20 list of works
that really matter
it would be tough for me to do um you
know i do these these
10 or you know i don't think i've ever
done a 20. i i do these lists every once
in a while in videos like i did the 10
works i would bring to a philosophical
10 philosophical works i would bring to
a desert island
i'm actually in the process of thinking
out who are my 10 favorite
um fiction writers that i keep going
back to over and over again um
but 20 lists that were a list of 20
works that really matter that's not a
bad idea
um
let's see here
a lot of people are
weighing in about i like this guy like
that guy
um
ah here's an interesting one thought
some from subconscious qualms
thoughts of which philosophers do you
think should be studied or explored more
so let's talk about this in a very
uh commercial metaphor
who are the undervalued stocks where
putting in the time will give you a
great return on investment
um i mentioned lev shestoff
i think lev chest off is a really great
writer he's not systematic
uh even in his is more
seemingly systematic works very
anti-systematic but but really really
worth reading
um again i i mentioned mary
wollstonecraft it's a shame that she's
not included
and there's other interesting women
writers too who aren't included in sort
of the standard history of you know
moral thought or things like that
her vindication of the rights of women
really worth reading
i think that if you're if you're uh
interested in an existentialist thought
somebody else who
is also worth worth reading who is
primarily a poet
but who has some very interesting
letters
uh is uh rainer maria rilke
i i enjoy going back to him over and
over and over again
he thought out a lot of stuff in his
letters and
there's an entire metaphysics sort of
underlying
his his poetic thought
particularly later in like the you know
do we know allergies
um
who else would i say
people don't read
that they they ought to read
you know actually let me let me start
with with ancient stuff
um we often start people out on you know
so read some plato read some aristotle
read some some stoics
um you know now read some epic cure
epicurus or maybe lucretius
and maybe sextus empiricus and boom
you're done right but maybe you read
some platinus as well but who are the
people that are kind of
overlooked in the ancient period that i
think are pretty cool um cicero i'm a
huge huge fan of this room i mean if you
want to
get to see somebody who studied with
some of the best representatives of
these philosophical schools churning
them over putting them into a different
language
um that's uh um
you know he's a great guy to read
um plutarch plutarch has you know
biographies that people read but he's
also got some really cool middle
platonus um discussions
of all sorts of topics i'm a big fan of
his
who else
[Music]
you know there's a lot of interesting uh
early christian writers
who are um not just i mean they're
they're high-powered thinkers and
they're trying to engage in thinking
ancient greek philosophy in relation to
christian thought clement of alexandria
i'm a big fan of his
uh i really like lactancias
um
he's got a really interesting
piece on divine anger
john chaosian is really worth reading
and then you know we can sort of like
march through the middle ages if you
haven't read bouetheus you definitely
need to read boethius
um
you know in in the modern period i think
that
um
somebody who
we don't typically read other than a
little portion of is um blaise pascal
and he is really fun to to read around
in um
that's probably enough of that
i'd probably go on all day if i
if i thought about that all right so
um
now dash asks the question that that i'm
not going to be able to answer but i
think it's a cool question so
i'm going to say it
right there's a passage in the hebrew
translation of after virtue that hebrew
readers will find complacency in
maimonides eight chapters in relation to
this book do you think it's adequate i i
wouldn't i wouldn't know you know i mean
i don't read hebrew
um
and uh
i um
you know i couldn't say but that's a
pretty cool question um
yeah
let's see here
oh here is a really challenging question
by protik
i have a question though it's out of the
topic that is how analytic philosophy
can help us in our life or as a practice
philosophy
so
i'm going to go on the record here and
say that at this point in time i don't
think there is any one single thing that
actually is analytic philosophy anymore
um some of my analytic trained friends
uh been talking for for you know decades
about being in a post-analytic
situation that is analytic philosophy it
did you at one time has to have sort of
a common history instead of projects
and now it's become sort of like a de
facto just way of doing things and it's
spun off into all these different
discourses
most of which are not communicating with
each other in any effective way
so you'll find the same terminology for
example being used in analytic
metaphysics uh but meaning something
very different say in
other discourses like in aesthetics or
philosophy of action or things like that
um can analytic philosophy really
function
uh in in our lives yeah i mean the whole
the whole training in you know
figuring out what the arguments are and
representing them clearly and then
looking at you know
whether press premises are questionable
or not
coming up with counter examples that's
all good stuff
um and a lot of people do that on their
own um without
you know studying contemporary analytic
philosophy but i think if if that
studying it helps you do that that's
great
um i don't know that there's that much
more guidance for for life um other than
in particular ways like if you're you
know worried about questions about
animal rights and you read some analytic
literature and animal rights that helps
you figure out how to treat your your
your pets or whether you should have
pets
that's good i guess
so i don't have that much to say about
that topic beyond that um
oh
rj grandl asks what are the main
prerequisites for reading heidegger's
what is metaphysics very interested in
it
but i'm not so sure i'm well-versed
enough to get a lot out of it
so that's actually a really great
question
um
there aren't any prerequisites
i mean this is this is one of the things
that i can say about many philosophical
works
you don't have to satisfy prerequisites
to read them
um
there's no philosophy police or
ratifying body that's going to say
you must read this first i mean there's
plenty of people
who will do that sort of thing
and they may do it for a variety of
reasons i'll give you sort of one bad
reason and then one good reason so one
bad reason is because they're caught up
in the prestige of of you know being an
expert on who they're teaching
or talking about or perhaps writing
their dissertation on and they they
think that you can't possibly understand
derrida if you haven't read this and
this and this and this you know
and you know quite frankly those people
are jerks
there's a lot of them
uh and i wouldn't listen to anything
that they have to say
because because typically they're wrong
um
but there is a lot of that kind of you
know
throwing things around oftentimes those
people that don't don't know about the
dairy diet or the heidegger or the plato
or the whoever right
um a good reason might be you know more
like giving somebody counsel and saying
well you know you'll get more out of
your reading of
acts
if you've already
understood
why that you're heading into
the reason why i like to use heidegger's
what is metaphysics
as an introductory text for students
in first grappling with heidegger's
thought is precisely because
it's
fairly basic um he's not going into a
lot of depth on things he does make a
few references to
uh
you know ways of thinking and a few
technical
discussions about you know logic and the
intellect and negation but i think it's
pretty accessible
and i mean here's the other thing i want
to say
when you when you're reading a
philosophical text expect to read it
and not and maybe get a bit out of it
and then reread it after you've you know
grappled with the ideas of it and get
more out of it it's an iterative process
and then read something else and then
come back to it and get more out of it i
mean i i put this in a comment on
somebody's youtube comment earlier today
but it's something that i say over and
over and over again to my students and
to lifelong learners
i've been studying thinkers like say
descartes or plato
or you know
aristotle or heidegger
many of them for you know more than two
decades
usually reading them very closely in the
original language teaching their text to
people
and either i must be a real dummy
you know and just not getting it
or
those texts are incredibly rich
because
i still keep finding more stuff in those
texts
um
and that's kind of amazing to me how
rich
these philosophical works can be
that
they reward further and further reading
so so i wouldn't be too too worried
about
prerequisites um
i would you know just just get into it
and and um
you know uh as you read other heidegger
stuff
some of the things that are in what is
metaphysics will probably click or or
you'll see additional depth to it you
know reading other things may may help
out as well um
all right so
uh
like i
got a little bit mixed up about where
the questions are
okay let me get back scroll up a little
bit
um
boy there's a lot of them
uh
i think they may have multiplied
in the process
um
a lot of discussion in here about jordan
peterson and and uh
um
removing pronouns
okay
where am i
i think i may end up skipping
over
a few things all right so i'm just going
to jump in here
um
brandon young writes james joyce
influenced so many philosophers
um
i have to admit i'm a i'm a philistine i
don't i don't enjoy a joyce
i tried reading ulysses for for a bit
and i was like and everybody had you
know talked it up so much and i was like
what the hell am i doing this for i
could be reading some other stuff
instead and i have a similar take on a
good portion of
modernist literature
so i'm a bad person to talk about that
sort of thing
um
ah william price asks
wondering what the status of half of our
hegel is we're studying the
phenomenology in a private group and
almost caught up to the end of your
youtube lectures there truly appreciated
thanks well that's amazing
because that's a lot of lectures
uh
and that's a huge investment of time um
i am approaching lecture 200
which i'm hoping to shoot
later tonight
actually 199 and 200 tonight
um
now on the public stuff
you don't actually see it i think it's
about
lecture 185 or 186 at this point but
that's because my patreon supporters of
the half hour hagel project get to see
the videos uh
you know a little bit in advance of
everybody else
so where are we i don't have my book
with me but we're about
i would say we're close to
um 60 done with the book we're in the
middle of the spirit section we're in
the second portion of spirit which is
very cool i never thought it would
get this far um it's taking me quite a
bit longer than i originally anticipated
uh it's a ton of work but it's very
rewarding
um it's not getting that much traction
in terms of like you know
people who write about digital
humanities
or you know um
you know that sort of stuff which i'm a
little disappointed in but uh i think we
we just have to do some more outreach in
in that respect
but anybody who who likes the half hour
hegel project you should like send in
you know things to to to people and like
the chronicle of higher ed or you know
new york times and say hey there's this
thing going on you guys should write
about it and and you know there's maybe
like a one percent chance that they will
but it's sort of like you know shooting
with a shotgun some of those pellets are
pounding somewhere um
yeah it's a cool project i i'm i'm
already getting a lot of inquiries about
what i'll do after that and i'm engaging
in some uh discussion with with some of
the people who've been like big fans and
supporters for
a long time about what would make sense
to do next i probably will tackle
another big thick book um
and i don't i'm not sure which one it
will be after that
um
let's skip down
uh
do a lot of discussion of jordan
peterson he seems to be
quite the topical guy
uh
oh brandon young writes another
interesting thing when i was a graduate
student almost no one was doing a thesis
in heidegger i was frowned upon very
much so
yeah so that's a really interesting
point when we talk about like the world
of philosophy
america we got to remember that there's
all these different philosophy programs
and each one is its own
animal
right they may be rather enamored of you
know
whatever the big
elite universities are doing and feel
like they need to catch up to them
but a lot of them are also doing their
own thing and they're their own echo
system you could say
so that's that's good to keep in mind um
i think we skipped up a little bit here
um
all right um
i want to wrap up pretty soon because
we're almost at the top of the hour
where i need to call somebody so i'm
going to try to grab
a few very short things i can respond to
paul sears steers hi greg i know this is
off topic but i know you're a fan
thoughts on the new game of thrones
season
um i think it's too short i don't think
seven or eight episodes is enough to
satisfactorily wrap things up
uh but otherwise it's you know it's
pretty good so like every all the the
chips are falling and uh there's there's
probably won't be many people left over
uh by the end um
let's see
there's a lot of people weighing in back
and forth about
continental and um
and analytic philosophy
um
all right i'll weigh in on two other
questions and then i'm going to
to get off very quickly
um
this is from francis persona what do i
think of djek's contributions to
contemporary re-understanding of hegel
i think that zizek is really doing
more zizek uh inspired by
hegel than than anything that's strictly
speaking hegel but then again
um anybody's free to do that sort of
thing if they want to
and um
you know
hegel hegel was wrong about some stuff
like the end of history you know so i
think
i i i don't always follow exactly what
what she is talking about and sometimes
i
you know when i do follow it i'm like
well i don't think that's right at all
i'm glad i guess i'm glad he's out there
bringing attention to hegel
um
stuff that he that he puts out but but
you know
it's it's so much of an investment to
just keep up with him so
uh
last one i'll take
uh
where was that now
shibboleth heidegger stole a lot from
kierkegaard and never admitted it
um
i don't know uh
i'd have to like dig back through there
i wouldn't say he stole from from
kierkegaard
uh it's a-okay in philosophy to
appropriate other people's
concepts
um and and work through them
um i know they you know
certainly jaspers and
marcel or contemporaries of heidegger
were drawing around ortega and gossett
drawing
ortega
we're drawing heavily on uh
kierkegaard
at the time
um i don't know that one i'd have to
think more about and what what exactly
counts as
stealing in this case so
right so i am going to
wrap it up here
and uh say thanks to everybody
um next time i'll make sure that i get
to see the questions
as they're popping up
thanks for everybody for joining me and
uh have a great day
you